Julie's next Julie is in Los Angeles hi
Julie welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave hey what's up in your world well
first I just want to thank you for your
show you're awesome and that you just
offer besides just money advice you
offer so much wisdom about money
marriage and relationships and I just
want to thank you've been so inspiring
thank you how can I help today
so here's my situation I am a single mom
with four kids and I'm going back to
school for nursing and every month I get
child support and alimony and I don't
have any kind of career and I'm going
back to school for nursing and every
month my parents are gracious enough and
kind enough to help me make it through
the month I went during the divorce I
was lucky enough to keep my home so my
kids environment stayed the same and I
have four of them so anywhere I would
move I would need a pretty you know
sizeable place I live in a very
expensive area and I've often thought do
I sell the home do I sweat it out do I
because every month I don't make it
how much is your house payment it's
2,200 and how much is your child support
your alimony
it ranges because he has over time and
it ranges like four to five thousand
dollars a month so what is your home
worth um probably seven hundred thousand
and I guess the question too is isn't
you've done what thousands and thousands
of ladies have done in your situation
that I've run into of there some are
able to pull it off some are but
basically you kind of said okay my kids
have gone through enough pain with this
divorce
I can't uproot them and give them any
more pain and so I'm going to keep the
house and sometimes that is okay and
sometimes it causes you to forget to do
math and try to keep a house you can't
keep so I guess one thing one way we
could look at your situation is say okay
when do you finish when you finish
nursing school well I've been chipping
a wave at it during the divorce and now
I'm getting to a point where I can apply
but the problem is applying to the
schools can take some time and then even
after you apply I'm a little bit out I
might have an opportunity to start this
may if not maybe the fall semester of
2014 if I get lucky enough to get in and
it's a two-year program from there yes
okay so five years from today you're a
nurse
oh please don't say that well is that
know what you want to be there no I mean
obviously you will have already been a
nurse for a while I didn't say he's
gonna take you that long I'm just saying
but let's visit five years let's visit
your life five years from today you're
no longer defined by child support and
alimony you're no longer defined by the
former mrs. so-and-so you are now a
nurse a single mom raising four kids are
you in this house at that point doesn't
nurse open a $750,000 house
I think um I would be able to yeah okay
um if he doesn't pay you can't um if he
doesn't pay you're not going to be
making $150,000 a year which is what you
need to make to have a 2,200 on our
house payment that time I try need to
make yeah it should be no more than 1/4
of your take-home pay and that means
you're taking home to end in 895 hundred
something like that and you know at that
point you might be if he pays everything
when he doesn't pay you how old are your
kids I have my twins are seven and a
half and then I have a 16 year old and a
17 year old okay so your child supports
getting ready cut in half before you get
on nursing school well it won't be in
half it it goes by okay but I mean it's
gonna drive half the kids are gone right
yeah yeah so um you may be able to keep
this house but I'm not going on what I
want to force you to do for for is to
say okay you know maybe we hold on to it
for two years and mom and dad subsidize
you and at the point you get on nursing
school and the kids leave you sell it
the
to leaf you know or something like that
but let's develop a plan here that works
for ten years and and even if it works
in stages for ten years let's not just
say all math doesn't count because my
babies are hurting because math counts
and the babies are going to hurt okay
know it counts no I'm not saying you
were that naive but there's a part of
you down inside the mama bear protecting
those kids pain that caused you to do
that that's like being a good mom I'm
not making fun of you but I'm just
saying I I think that's why you've got
yourself in this pickles I think you got
a house that you can't afford today and
my only question is is it worth fighting
to keep it a few years because you can
afford it tomorrow or do we just go
ahead and admit it now and that yeah
that's kind of my question and I don't
know I mean you know how wealthy are mom
and dad I mean they're not like swimming
in you know dough but I make a year I I
don't know my dad is an inventor and
sells a product and he does pretty well
at that a couple of hundred or what I'm
sure probably yeah okay how much they
given you a month they usually ranges
from like 700 to probably 1500 what I
would do is sit down with them and
develop a strategy in a game plan that
they're willing to agree to mama dad I'd
like to stay here for
I know but indefinitely no and you don't
want help indefinitely you want to be on
your own again and so if you sit down
say mom and dad if you can do this do
1500 a month for two years until I get
out of nursing school or two and some
change then I should be okay with this
house at that point I may sell it but
between now and then that allows the
kids some time to heal and the oldest
two to get out of the house and you know
maybe that's your plan that seems like a
good plan if mom and dad can afford to
help you but you need definition and
clarity to your plan things in
perpetuation or what add stress to your
life especially things that are
unpleasant this is the Dave Ramsey show
you